ボールを舐めが弾み節夫最近ガスケット道にハマってるんだ
同大僕のボールさばき
場所がないからまたばっかりボード投資ですけど崩れてくれっ
ええええええ
はぁ
かっこいいよねっ
だけどこれを作ろうと思いますそしてず気づいてなんですけど僕ので下スプーンが
バスケットしかないんですよ運動しなきゃと思ってきましてちょっと家で
バスケットボールをしていると思ったらね
ボールわかったんですけどボルでこうやってやってても実践的な練習にはならないので
今大会に
植わりとガッツリマジなバスケットゴールを買いましたこちら
やっぱバスケット校
[拍手]
はいというわけで日バスケットこれがあればシュート練習もドリブルもできるわけです
よ
マジで本格的にバスケットボール家で始めたいんですけど大会に行くのもめんどくさい
しいえどちゃんが2体感がないので今回バスケットゴールお家に帰りました大家さんと
バスケットボールをしたいと思います1人がそれゆえバスケットボール買う奴なんて
そういないかな
俺と今回歴史的な試みになると思います上げていきましょう
家の完成図はこんな感じですね普通にバスケットができます
うんっ
バッハリングだわかんないよああああんっひょっとして大変かなテーマで作るの大変
そうなんだけど
し何としても僕は家でバスケットボールがした今日はなんと白
バスケットゴールを作りますでは行こうあっても4つ繰り前田経験できちゃうんです
けどパス券ってこれで難しいんですねほらちょっとなにメール送ってくる
3名推奨一人でやっていないよ
これを入れるあ
[音楽]
ん
はいというわけで地下走行なら多分作れると思うので
4月地下倉庫でバスケットゴールを作ります全然高さ考えてなかったんでこれだけた方
があれば絶対作れると思うんで高高ないとバスケできないで地下で作りますでは
あああああわあ
[拍手]
はあああああデー
はぁ
car
tan
par
ああああああああ
[拍手]
maji ona
ん
[音楽]
た
母ん
ハーフ2
[音楽]
はあああああああ
tel r
th
立っ
庭師完成かもしれません
はいというレベルだって頃参加しましたーー
でわーバッハの
car
まあ的にこっちだったよ
ん
はっはっは
too
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はいというれ無事バスケットゴールが完成しました
これでいいのか
1でもバスケットボールができる2連射できるのはかなり北嬉しいです目は最初の1本
目きます
me
tan
teame
car
re だった